the Headless Horseman rides tonight
through stark and starless skies shatter
in the silence with his otherworldly
cries he races through the darkness on
his alabaster steed the Headless
Horseman rides tonight wherever the
fates would lead after the video on the
Dullahan it seemed like many of you were
interested in the origins of the
Headless Horseman so today we'll take a
look at some Headless Horseman stories
from a few different countries
the first headless horseman story is one
that some of you might be quite familiar
with because it's a story that was
popularized by Washington Irvine in
American folklore the Headless Horseman
was originally known as the headless
Hessian of the hollow his story begins
in New York during the Battle of White
Plains just one of the many battles that
took place in America's fight for
independence from the British the
horseman was a hessian trooper who took
part in the battle Hessian troopers for
those of you who don't know were German
soldiers who fought for the British
during the battle this particular
hessian trooper was unlucky enough to be
decapitated by a cannonball his body
would be carried away by his comrades
but his head which had been shattered
into pieces was left scattered around
the battlefield his remains were then
buried in the old Dutch Church of Sleepy
Hollow and legend has it that he would
rise as a vengeful ghost in search for
his lost head
the reason this tale was often
associated of Halloween and why the
Horseman's head is sometimes depicted as
a pumpkin is because the battle took
place on the 28th of October only a few
days before the holiday
the idea of the horsemen being
decapitated in battle is quite common
and it's one that we see in Scottish
Welsh and English folklore in both
English and Welsh folklore we have the
14th century or thorium poem Sir Gawain
and the Green Knight this story centers
around one of the Knights of Arthur's
round table who is challenged to a duel
by a mysterious Green Knight but this in
itself isn't really a duel as the Green
Knight tells Gawain that he will allow
him to strike him once and then he will
return the same blow a year and a day
later and Gawain accepts this challenge
and with one swing of his axe he manages
to decapitate the Green Knights but the
knight then simply picks up his head
reminds Gawain that he will return in a
year's time and goes on his way when he
eventually finds this mysterious Green
Knight kawin accepts his fate and in an
attempt to keep his honor he leans over
expect in the night to return the blow
and strike him down
after several Fink's wings of his axe
and a brief exchange the Green Knight
explains to Gawain that he was actually
transformed by Arthur's sister Morgan la
Fey and this whole challenge and
adventure was merely just a ploy to
expose Arthur's knights and to show how
chivalrous they really were and this
story is quite long and there certainly
are some things that I haven't mentioned
and that's because I'd like to cover
this in some more detail when I start
discussing these stories of King Arthur
and our Thorian lore itself in Scotland
the Headless Horseman was said to be a
man named Ewan who fought for leadership
of his clan during a battle on the Isle
of model both Ewan and his horse were
decapitated and thus and in his hopes
have ever been the chieftain but the
legends state that both man and horse
still haunt the surrounding area even to
this day
for our next legend we travel all the
way to northern India and the state of
Rajasthan this variation of the Headless
Horseman was seen as a more heroic
figure who was said to protect the
innocent and these stories usually
describe the horsemen as being born from
a violent death
the most common story is about a prince
who was decapitated while defending his
village from the thieves even once he
was beheaded he continued to defend his
people and this version of the horseman
was said to fight without a horse so he
isn't really a horseman but there is a
story of a God who died defending his
prince in battle despite his death the
God continued to defend his prince and
he enters the battle mounted on a horse
without a head
our last two stories take us to Germany
where the Brothers Grimm wrote several
stories about the Headless Horseman the
first story set in the town of Dresden
and follows a woman who is gathering
acorns in a part of the forest named the
loss to waters the woman then hears the
sound of a hunting horn and when she
turns she sees a man riding a grey horse
which isn't too out of the ordinary so
she continues collecting acorns and goes
home when she later returned to the
forest she heard a voice from behind her
and when she turned she saw the same man
dressed in grey this time carrying his
head under his arm he then tells a woman
that his name is Hans Hasan tofu and
during his life he never once did he do
warnings of his father to be courteous
and merciful to all those below him he
often drank excessively and indulged
himself far too much without a care for
those around him and so now in death he
was cursed to roam the earth as an evil
spirit the second story is of the wild
Huntsman of Brunswick the Huntsman went
by the name of hackleburg and on his
death he begged God to allow him to stay
on earth and in exchange he would
sacrifice his place in heaven his
request would be granted but he would
remain on earth as a headless horseman
hackleburg was said to blow his horn to
warn other hunters that the next day
would not be safe for hunting in some
stories he would even seek out and
punish those who had wronged to others
accompanied by his pack of black hounds
with tongues of fire and these two
stories certainly tie into the themes of
God and morality that we see all
throughout the Grimm stories most of
these tales despite where they're from
seem to share a similar origin the
horseman is nearly always driven by
revenge often slain in a battlefield of
some kind then of course you have
stories where the horseman is more of a
protector figure and even a vigilante
I'm sure many of you would have heard
similar stories so feel free to share
those with me in the comments below as
always I've been your host mythology and
fiction explained
you